what's going on reject nation it's greg
out here and it's john here so we
thought in honor of whoops potent more
code more for the planet of the apes
coming out we would give our list for
our five favorite prequels of all time
yeah now this is my five and this is job
five real hot back-and-forth keep in
mind now this is really important
i need you to keep in mind this is our
opinion yeah they're also aren't that
many prequel yes so don't feel the need
to kill us if you're pretty cool isn't
on this blip we didn't forget it we just
chose an inline with what we like yeah
okay it's subjective comment hopefully
you can understand that your movie is
also valid
alright i'll kick off the list so my
number five pick is arguably the best
film out of any film john mariano list
today arguably gregory arguably arguably
but the reason why I'm naked at number
five is because only half of it is a
prequel and that is the Godfather Part
two now The Godfather Part two fun fact
you know this question was on the Schmo
down what character has been portrayed
by two different actors that has also
won an Oscar for both for trails and
that was Vito Corleone Marlon Brando
Robert De Niro and it is also the only
sequel in movie history that has won
best picture as well with its
predecessor also winning best veteran
Return of the King won but [ __ ] for
the ring and two towers did not win The
Godfather Part two people might debate
you know which one's your favorite
personally I find Godfather Part two to
be my personal favorite honestly a lot
of it does have to do with its prequel
story would see the origins of Vito
Corleone they should have called this
veto Corleone origins never know how I
get an adamantium skeleton yeah because
you know as much as we really got to
know Marlon Brando's character as Vito
Corleone and Godfather Part 1 I really
feel like he becomes even even more
three-dimensional a fully-fledged and
you see a transformation in an arc take
place with that and it was just cool to
see a historical piece take place
primarily in Italy and then old-school
New York it was super fascinating and
yours killed the role so yeah Godfather
Part 2 probably the best film out of my
personal 5 picks here but it's I put it
as number 5 just because only half a
pretty cool my 5 is similar you know
it's probably the best film on my list
arguably this is also you know a period
piece of throwback going back to the
Civil War days my choice is good the bad
and the ugly and I think I actually
probably started before us our Fistful
of Dollars and I think a lot of people
said yeah yeah that title I think the
first year were foreign films just
considered foreign films and the good
the bad the ugly actually got a an
American release yeah right away this is
a movie I should probably go back and
re-watch again now because I grew up I
this was one of those classics that I
grew up with I watch this for the first
time with my mom I think we even rented
it to I cause I know I've seen it at
least a couple times on TV you got any
of Morricone ease arguably like the most
iconic theme of everything yes or no of
any Western and I'll throw it up there
for movie history you know and I mean
even though you know it is a good sized
movie it takes its time definitely but
there's nothing like the heat and the
stickiness and and the compelling Nassif
again a westerns and under Sergio
Leone's direction that is it it's an
incredible movie I don't pull it out all
the time because I like crave to watch
it you know necessarily it is more of a
film to me than it is a movie I would
put on if I want to relax but with you
know Eli while I can leave and Cleveland
and Clint Eastwood together all three of
them let's stand off at the end as far
as westerns go that's like a gold
standard and yeah nice to have a western
on the list do you know man that's a
tough western end and all of you don't
realize it's actually a prequel yeah you
just got to do this cuz I didn't know
man you gotta do the math on it to go oh
so okay I see how it's a prequel yeah
yeah okay so my number four pick is the
one where I feel crap coming my way and
that is rogue one a Star Wars story Oh
rogue one a Star Wars story pleasantly
surprised me I don't like the three
prequels before that you know episodes
one two and three
the rogue one what I really appreciate
about this film as a guy who considers
himself a Star Wars fan of the movies on
all admit I don't go out of my way to
play the video games or watch
TV shows but in terms of the movies I've
seen them all multiple times even the
ones that don't like you release read
the novelization how many hours a week
do you spend researching this rich
Christian art right yeah even though all
the movies have the title of Star Wars
in it this was the first time I really
felt that a director was embodying the
world war it had a full-fledged war vibe
about it that I really did enjoy it was
darker and it felt completely different
than the other Star Wars films I felt a
lot more human and more grounded and
some of the best battle sequences I've
seen out of any of the Star Wars movies
and I thought it provided something
fresh and different for a story that we
didn't really need but yet it felt like
a delightful surprise and felt necessary
after I watched it granted leading up to
it I was like this doesn't sound like a
necessary movie just sounds like a
marketing ploy but I was I really
appreciated the music in it I
appreciated the direction in it all the
performances I thought were fantastic I
loved that they killed off all these
characters and that's what I learned she
started to give you a heads up there I
really appreciate this film as a and
more than just a space opera film that
felt like a grounded space opera film
actually to me and really human loved a
smaller space Wars my number four on
this list is actually a pretty recent
movie as well I chose Ouisa origin of
evil that you know came out of what last
year anything is we see so many movies
but yeah we George did Aviva really
surprised me and you know the buzz was
good but but seeing it all come together
I really like that they took it back
they made it a period piece and I really
liked the fact that they chose you know
to have this sort of single mothers
story and the way that they improved
upon the first one I was pretty blown
away by the second one I liked it a lot
you know it got me kind of in every way
like it made me feel I thought it was
you know well written I liked the
characters was also creepy and scary and
trying to gave me everything I want and
it left an impression on me to me like I
think back and I still remember that I
remember that movie thinking that the
director was very much aware
audience and you know when they would
think this scare is coming it kind of
army of James Wan did it yeah yeah yeah
my planning is a pretty smart director
and it shows in this movie I like this
new trend of sequels or prequels even
you know second installments that think
outside the box to improve upon the
original each origin of evil has that in
spades for me so my number three pick
would have to be double a seventh Casino
Royale boy I really do love this sound
out of all the Daniel Craig film Skyfall
is the biggest box-office success
some people consider that one their
favorite for me personally Casino Royale
was the definition of what we tip with
reboots nowadays but done in the right
way you know make it darker grittier
more grounded and realistic stripped
away the gadgets and get a little more
still special when that movie yeah it
was because I was embargo with reboot
syndrome yeah this format of doing that
I feel like I see no help to build that
blueprint and I really appreciated that
Daniel Craig brought it back to because
I think I feel like Sean Connery took
the role of Bond seriously and then you
get other later additions where like
Roger Moore is kind of the Campea
version and he's still good and what
he's doing I really appreciate a
democratic brought it back to this
really strong sense of realism
I think it's shot incredibly well the
action scenes are super memorable and is
the first time we get a bond origin
movie without going too crazy with
origin details to the point where you
feel like you can't do with the story
would have to end by the time daniel
craig's movies are done one thing that I
feel like a lot people don't touch on is
why bond is so emotionally detach from
the women encounters and why he decides
to repress all this like you see a
repressive side to all these qualities
that we would see a bond but now you see
the human version of what caused him to
develop in to see as much she's mo
closed-off sexist kind of dude take it
close to anybody except for Abed they
had a poker scene that entire sequence
was super intense when it's going from
the breaks in the between the poker game
and then going back to the poker game I
loved how it brought it to bond skills
in terms of up here and it's fit
and not just in relying on gadgets and
cue the hold on my number three is this
is a movie that I know a good amount of
people don't love but I grew up with it
and I watched it a ton as a kid I
watched it into my adulthood and I I'm
just big Temple of Doom fan Indiana
Jones - ripping that heart clean out the
chest PG that movies right Indiana Jones
of the temple Doom is definitely the
darkest and the most wacked-out of the
four wealth of the three movies not we
don't go with it for lack now but yeah
we don't need a diamond Temple of Doom
at I just have a a ton of fun watching
that movie but also you know it's McCobb
and freaky it satisfies the horror fan
in me and I think just the the designs
and the concepts of everything are
really cool that got John yeah even
though there are some problematic things
about that movie like even as a kid man
I wanted to be short round yeah I just
wanted to be in these buddy I wanted to
be Silber ex-wife take care and I heard
about I recognize that there aren't
there are some things in about that
movie that are not perfect but
everything about that movie is charming
to me in some way it was color also
worried at that sequences yeah and
that's the thing is like when they have
him like strapped to a table and they're
making him drink out of a skull like or
didn't went on the bridge and he has to
cut the rope that was crazy yeah that's
like a craziness nicer yeah like it's
shot really well so this is a movie that
is one of those ones for me were like
even though I understand some of like
logically some happiness accumulated
over the years my heart just doesn't
matter weaker of the trilogy but I still
I still really enjoy not gonna like skip
it
yeah I'm still glad to watch it and
we're doing a marathon you know and I
still have a great time watching it so
my number two pick is film where it's
one of those trilogy prequels and I was
debating is the second or throw because
all three of them are great but I'm
going with the one that I just had to
follow my heart and I'm going with the
second one dawn of the Planet of the
Apes now don't get me wrong I think war
for the plan of the apes is an amazing
fantastic
the best movies of 2017 but in terms of
dawn of the Planet of the Apes that was
something to me that provided a lot more
of what I really wanted I'm not going to
do a comparison game here but with Donna
the planet Yves I really loved the
debate of everything that's going on
because what was really special me about
that film was the first like 10 to 15
minutes you don't see a single human
being it's only the Apes and you're
engrossed in it that by the time the
human shows up it was kind of weird yeah
like oh yeah this human is really good
yeah it's a Bozzio thing Clark I feel
like a lot of the time you set up with
humans and then you see the Ava and the
Apes look weird with CGI and stuff where
the heaven complete opposite effect
that I really did respect a lot I love
the kind of futuristic apocalyptic touch
it was having and I really appreciated
that it took this origin tale to show
that it wasn't you know Caesar versus
humans and I hate just hates humans so
he's declaring war that the phone was
really about that they're just scared
and they don't know what to do it's a
great film where you see both sides to
the human side and the ape side and it's
building to this finale where by the
time the finale goes all out and it's
crazy amazingly shot stylized action
sequences you don't want them to fight
it's like I know it's supposed to go
down this path you know this is all
supposed to happen but you don't want
neither one of them to fight because you
don't view the Apes as bad and you don't
be the humans as bad
you can just see they're both afraid of
each other and they don't know and they
really don't know how to handle the
situation is because of that feeling of
emotional debate and turmoil that I was
feeling where you get all the cool
trailer sequences yet you're like oh
this is a nightmare I want to watch I
was like it gets me like uncomfortable
when I'm watching it but it's like a
good kind of uncomfortable to be sitting
through for me I felt like war for the
plenty of the best Caesar performance
taking him to a level of more than just
an ape learning how to do human
qualities it was fascinating to see the
ape culture come into fruition in that
specific film I feel like either explore
the ape culture and the human culture at
that time and then watch the world clash
which I really appreciate it my number
two just piggy backing out for yours
is war for the planet ES and I really
like Don we watched it together you're
actually making me appreciate that move
you sort more just hearing you talk
about it but war for me was the one that
really like knocked me out like that
movie blew me away and it have been a
little you know a little time since I've
seen Don and that movie to me is in
terms of all the blockbusters I've seen
lately and that was the one that
scratched that potential of like this is
something I think is great this is the
potential that that we have with
blockbuster movies to tell both a really
compelling and really resonant you know
storing and also you know deliver like
you said the trailer stuff I feel like
they both share that and the thing I
appreciate it so much about war is the
fact that for so long you're you're
mostly with the Apes now and so much of
it is without dialogue and so much of it
it's through body language and there's
so much trust building and so I got
really invested in the unfolding a story
that took its time and then just that
particular cast of ape side characters
and human side characters everything and
that one came together to scratch all
the John itch is you know I feel like
that one's more of a John movie than
dawn is baby yeah it's been a few weeks
since we've seen it now and I'm still
thinking about yeah whenever I see the
poster like and I'm billboards or
anything on my casa school movie aside I
think it's great yeah and that's maybe
like implied kept on impressing me kept
on pulling in further and I was already
you know interested in going to check
out yeah I feel like the reason I
specifically with them a little more
gravitated towards Don and it's not to
try to persuade you to take it off with
I'm a little bit more gravitate towards
dawn because I like the equal balance of
seeing good humans and seeing apes as
well and don't lie as far as I felt like
wars like behave ones are pretty much as
bad you know
but even that way I'm surprised to me we
can't talk too much but things I thought
would be hammy or cliche about the
trailer came up in the movie and
surprised me with how much I was like
okay yeah good on you movie like you
really thought of everything I know and
I also felt to that dawn also what does
deliver on like the action thrills
whereas I feel like warm I let down some
people yeah because it's not really that
much action in the film yeah I'm not
quite as concerned with getting that
especially from the planet having seen a
lot of The Avengers the Charlton have
someone Jam half as a full-blown action
sequences both huge scale yeah well it's
basically heard a man already is early
age with an assault rifle the massacre
comes on t17 yeah most violent movie
they did it all right so the number one
choice John and I actually share this as
our number one choice so we're just
going to present together John what is
it
it is x-men origins Wolverine Wolverine
no thanks man I'm finished called and
finally figure out we got that jacket
yeah great x-men first class man first
class this film to me is an absolute
delight is no doubt the most fun x-men
movie of them all that movie has a more
fun than left yeah it has this rhythm
this pace it has this energy that
Matthew Vaughn is known to bring to his
comic book adaptation enters he's done a
billion of those yeah energy and edge to
having we always bring he manages that
uncanny balance of edginess but also fun
yeah yeah and it's a period piece that I
really did enjoy it was a surprise great
performance from Kevin Bacon as the
villain yes and when you're coming off
of the heels of Patrick Stewart and Ian
McKellen as Magneto and Professor X and
you get James McAvoy and Michael
Fassbender who aren't as well
established at the time to be in these
roles those are big shoes to fill and
they bring a totally different approach
yet you could see how it blends well
with they did they made it their own and
their powerful performances because the
whole time in the x-men franchise when
you're hearing about Professor X and
Magneto they used to be buddies and all
that stuff but that's all into that
history it's all felt history here you
really get to see that history and you
know what's going down a path where
they're going to part ways but it does
one of my favorite prequel things where
it looks similar with dawn and war where
you don't want to go down this happy you
know what's going to it has that same
effect like I want you guys to be best
friends or so good as best friends
and then there but you know they're
going to go down that path and they're
going to have to be enemies but you can
see where all that history is linking to
why they never just killed each other
how there's always been an understanding
and a mutual respect despite their
differences yeah I remember x-men first
class being a very gratifying first view
because that's sort of a return to form
from a couple hiccup
dudes last fan or if you think in the
French I should die if anything that
reinvigorated the franchise yeah yeah
and and bringing in new blood too even
though they change directors for a few
things before it really seemed like
Matthew Vaughn came in and brought some
new things with him but also return to
some of the things that make an x-men
movie great yeah you know and I was
pleased to see not only did they go
period peace with it which is I feel
like of all the the prequel gimmicks I
feel like that's a pretty good one yeah
like that that gives you a lot to work
with without restricting you too hard
and I thought that was a nice choice it
was fun to see the x-men in a different
era borrow from different history and
also just I thought the ensemble they
got together was great I love all this
stuff with the Russian missiles yeah
that was amazing missiles yeah well
Russia key they were connected to okay
yeah but so yeah yeah and like bring it
into the missile present the Cold War on
that thing I also appreciate is the
ballots kind of like you talked about
with with Don of the planet EA so where
you have you know I'm compelled by the
characters I'm compelled by where the
story's going I'm enjoying seeing this
team come together they're building the
threat nicely and then you do get some
big satisfying action that still feels
like it's on the scale of x-men because
one of my biggest complaints about
apocalypse is that it breached the cap
of where x-men movies live for me and
jumped out into something else and so I
thought the x-men first class managed to
be fully satisfying and kind of fully
its own thing but also you know on while
keeping alive what I thought was great
about the x-men movies and distinct
about the x-men movies and it's just a
great Hugh Jackman cameo singing that
yeah well anyway guys that's our list
for our favorite prequels of all time
what are your favorite prequels what
prequels did we not mention that you
think really
should be on this list which five other
make sure they're like equal real
prequels because we know some people say
like Dada nan begin is a prequel but I'm
like that's an origin story it's not a
pretty cool to any specific Batman movie
you know it's not a prequel to like the
Michael Keaton version or something and
some people might say Wonder Woman is
but to me that's just another like
origin universe story it's like sure
technically fin all PBS or something
yeah yeah I wanted to use that glare but
we went and here it just went for like
clear-cut prequels how that was gonna do
that yeah you have any runners-up before
we hit the road yeah the hobbit the
desolation of smaug whatever the first
one's called first one called hobbit
journey of the boredom oh very yeah
massacre the beginning I don't know I
don't like duty three yeah a lot of fun
Simon came to my mind is a lot that that
that is like if we had a an extra slide
just for like ads yeah fun and creative
I like that bill creation trailer
alright guys well subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell dat
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
social media manager of Blum House
please go check out our exclusive perks
and rewards over at patreon.com slash
the Rio relax
check out our t-shirt design shop
stretcher.com slash the real rejects you
have a good day a watch war for the plum
of the apes immediately